thank you oh you're so you're too kind
these Tick Tock to blame when your kid
goes insane and will big tech pay the
price for treating our kids like
laboratory mice well several school
districts are suing social media Giants
alleging they're contributing to a
mental health crisis among our nation's
youngest most impressionable Minds some
educators are so upset over this they've
stopped hitting on their students
Seattle Public Schools took time off
from calling everything racist and filed
the first lawsuit back in January
arguing social media companies designed
and marketed their sites to attract
miners Seattle schools said media
companies should instead teach kids the
basics like how to make a Molotov
cocktail
most recently Bucks County Pennsylvania
filed a suit against Tick-Tock Instagram
Facebook Snapchat and YouTube officials
there claiming those platforms actually
encourage youth addiction and have
exploited developing Minds without
consequence exchanging our children's
mental well-being for billions in ad
Revenue in a statement of Fox News meta
previously Facebook said it's developed
more than 30 tools to support teens and
families so do I actually
this from Mark Zuckerberg who named his
initial creation face smash a Hot or Not
game that allowed visitors to compare
two students faces side by side and let
them decide who was more attractive so
trusting him with your teens I don't
know would be like trusting Hunter Biden
to get your laptop fixed
Dr Drew uh you're a doctor or so you
claim uh what do you think can you blame
this on the social what's happening oh
one oh wait let me ask you let me ask
you a different question what are the
symptoms what is this causing so the
most obvious manifestations are in
younger females and teenage girls
depression suicide overall anxiety
depression substance use it is a
disaster for young people's mental
health and then covid put that all on
steroids as you say not the fun kind yes
and the schools sent kids home with pads
with electronic pads exposure to porn
went up sexting went up distress went up
it is out of control there's everything
you read that's being alleged is
categorically true I don't know how they
get from out from under this because we
will one day look at the screens where
we look at tobacco for sure now there so
you're talking that cat did you hear
what he said he complained it to smoking
now you could say that we do ban stuff
smoking and alcohol for children uh but
does it work I mean is that should we be
doing that with social media is social
media like an actual substance that you
that the teen ingests
um yeah I don't know if it works I I
don't I don't know if you're able to
actually do that if it's going to be
available to keep kids from going on it
I mean I did smoke a cig before I was
18. me too yeah like it's not I and my
parents were very strict but they
couldn't keep me in cigs away all the
time so I think that it's still possible
it's about parents I mean I never had to
deal with cyber bullying growing up I I
deal with it now and like the people you
know it's like I didn't do it as a kid
but now I'm being Cyber Bullied by
people old enough to be these kids
grandparents or even my grandparents but
did it ever occur to you that those are
the wives of the older men that you just
think
I love you too wives
uh don't listen to what your husband
says
I don't know but some of them are
there's this one guy named Dan yeah who
just says horrible things about me every
single night he never has other plans so
he's a bully and a loser wow um but I
think so it's parents they need to like
pay attention to what their kids are
doing online yes but also like what me
me are you are you being jerks do your
kids see you being jerks online because
if they see you being a jerk maybe they
think it's okay for them to be jerks
it's not just the being jerks part this
part of it is also again we need to sue
all the hot people so well there's that
comparing it's the you know it's the
sexting it's the porn of exposure and
it's what porn exposure now average age
is like nine or something that's crazy
yeah it's super crazy that's crazy well
I didn't have a cell phone growing up
but uh I had a bit of a dirty childhood
yes except it was different you couldn't
pick up a phone you have to go into the
woods and find that little stack of
pornos yes that somebody uh left and
then you and your friends would do
things and never acknowledge it again to
each other that's what it was like until
you're on TV in front of millions of
people oh yeah guess what I used to do
when I was a boy yeah and they all know
it was it was more of a challenge that
was those were the adventurous days when
we were a young PAB so we're we're
learning that children are also uh uh
obsessed with status like it's another
thing like for example when I was
growing up I had no idea what my
neighbors what my neighbor's parents did
for a living how much money they had if
they had a swimming pool I didn't know I
was friendless alone sad but I didn't
know I didn't know people were having a
better time than me but if there was
Instagram I would know everybody was
having a better time that would drive me
nuts yes absolutely I'd say ignorance is
bliss and uh when I was growing up you
know there were probably parties that I
wasn't invited to and you know sometimes
you'd get a sense that maybe there were
things you were missing but you never
really knew for sure and now you know
for sure and it isn't just the kids who
are damaged by that I I know a lot of
people my age who are just you know they
see something on Facebook oh my gosh all
of my friends got together and I wasn't
invited and it's very hurtful to all
ages but when it comes to the kids you
know the comparison to smoking I think
think is accurate because they were
arguing back then that they were
manipulating the nicotine to make it
maximally addictive the same way they
say they're manipulating social media
they've studied the brain and figured
out how to get you to keep going and
going on it and they're supposedly doing
it on purpose but it goes back to the
question of how do you stop it yeah well
I'm going to say that the ins in person
you know emphasizing P humans in space
flesh meeting is really important
because that's what makes people healthy
more time on the screen less emotions
but Jim shouldn't these kids just grow
up atta boy Greg you know
parents
stop whining parents are the blame you
know I mean like they don't they're
spoiled like when I was a kid if I like
if I got a a math question wrong yeah I
got burned with a cigarette or hit
across the teeth with the phone
but then I made sure I studied my math
yes there you go and now you know you
should thank your parents as I do often
sometimes I'll call my mom I'll look at
a scar and I'll go thanks Mom you're
welcome to go who is this
Jim I told you never to call me
yeah so I think part of it is the
parents too yeah there you go boy it's
everybody's fault yep all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else